(whooshing, squeaking)
(uptempo bluegrass music)
- Do you think farts are funny?
(laughing)
- Yeah
Yeah, I do.
- Yeah?
Why?
- I don't know why, I
just think they're funny.
- No.
- No?
- No, they're not funny.
- Do you think farts are funny?
(laughing)
- The really noisy ones.
- The really noisy ones are funny?
- No.
- Farts?
- They are.
- Yeah?
- Yes.
- Uh, no.
- So you've never laughed at a fart?
- Oh yeah, of course, yeah.
- So then sometimes they're funny?
- Yeah, sometimes.
(farting)
(laughing)
- Yeah, they are.
- Yeah, without a doubt.
- Hilarious.
- What makes farts funny?
- I think the
(laughing)
suspense of them makes them pretty
funny.
(farting)
- There it is.
(laughing)
- It depends.
- Have you ever laughed at a fart?
- I'm sure I have, I'm British.
So we find that kind of stuff funny.
(farting)
- Like that, yeah.
That's pretty good.
- Thanks.
(laughing)
- Do you think farts are funny?
- Clearly.
- Definitively.
(laughing)
Definitively.
I mean, I don't know
when they're not funny.
They might be inappropriate,
but it doesn't mean it's not funny.
Those are two different things.
- Do you think farts are funny?
- No.
- Farts aren't funny?
- I'm done.
- Farts are hilarious.
- Sometimes.
(farting)
(laughing)
- No.
- I think they're funny, yeah.
(farting)
(laughing)
- Not really, sometimes.
(farting)
(gasping)
(laughing)
- Excuse me.
(farting)
- Was that funny?
(laughing)
- So, what do you think?
(whooshing, squeaking)